[Musique]
l'édition spéciale de TV 78 à
l'université des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien se poursuit et on va parler de
du sujet qui fait l'actualité
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie
notamment pour les communes avec nous
pour en parler Yann perron bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le maire de
Gargenville
Jean-Baptiste savonic avec nous bonjour
bonjour maire de Villepreux et Elisa
Queru bonjour bonjour directrice
régionale de Total énergie régionale
Île-de-France de Total énergie et
justement on va commencer avec vous
avant de parler de du coup de l'énergie
ce qui fait aussi l'actualité c'est la
pénurie de carburant que subissent les
français et notamment les Franciliens
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
est la situation à l'heure actuelle au
niveau de l'Île-de-France
peut-être un élément de contexte
tout cela intervient à un moment où les
stations Total énergie appliquent une
remise d'aide au pouvoir d'achat de 20
centimes donc avec une logistique déjà
et une influence dans notre station
au-delà de notre part de marché qui fait
que toute la logistique dans nos
stations-service était déjà contraintes
et et sous tension à cela en effet
des certaines raffineries en France sont
rentrés dans un dans un mouvement dans
un mouvement de grève ce qui voilà il y
a du produit mais ce qui complique
encore la chaîne d'approvisionnement
logistique pour que en continu on essaie
justement de trouver des moyens pour
approvisionner les stations services
donc on continue toujours à mettre en
oeuvre ses moyens pour assurer
l'approvisionnement et puis par ailleurs
évidemment il est important de
de poursuivre le dialogue social et donc
les organisations syndicales seront
reçues une à une par la direction cet
après-midi pour essayer voilà de trouver
des solutions constructives on a bien
conscience de l'impact pour pour les
Franciliens pour les Français et donc il
y a il est important de d'essayer de
trouver les solutions si les blocages se
terminent il faut combien de temps pour
que ce ça revienne à la normale à peu
près c'est compliqué à dire parce que en
fonction des des situations et des
implantations c'est vrai que comme
encore une fois il y a du produit le
problème il est pas dans les stocks le
problème il est sur la chaîne logistique
donc il faut que tout ça se mette en
place j'attire aussi l'attention sur le
comportement sur le fait que il sait
aussi important voilà d'essayer de
fluidifier même si c'est pas simple
puisque c'est tout à fait normal d'être
inquiet mais d'essayer de se dire que
voilà globalement les choses peuvent se
dérouler correctement donc c'est aussi
important de se dire que on en termes
d'influence dans les stations on essaie
réguler un petit peu tout ça pour que
les choses se passent le mieux possible
avant de parler d'électricité et de gaz
comment ça se passe dans les mairies
comment vous gérez aussi cette pénurie
de carburant parce que vous utilisez des
véhicules notamment vos services
techniques
si je peux me permettre bah écoutez
c'est particulièrement compliqué on a
déjà depuis une semaine engagée une
phase d'économie de rationnement des
déplacements des agents aujourd'hui je
crois qu'on est arrivé au plus bas de
nos stocks et il faut intervenir de
manière non motorisée et donc c'est un
petit peu compliqué pour l'ensemble de
nos équipes mais ils vont devoir s'y
faire et on reportera à plus tard
certains travaux qui engagé des
véhicules motorisés évidemment et vous
Jean-Baptiste à Monique sur la commune
de Villepreux on est dans la même
situation on a évidemment rationné le
carburant pour permettre à l'ensemble
des services de poursuivre les missions
qui sont les leurs en espérant
évidemment que cette crise du carburant
soit
rapidement derrière nous et je remercie
l'ensemble des acteurs mobilisés et j'ai
une pensée évidemment pour les Yvelinois
et également nos amis des Hauts-de-Seine
qui sont qui sont touchés tous les
Franciliens évidemment le son c'est
délicat moi j'ai changé avec mes
services techniques qui ont besoin
d'intervenir sur la commune la police
municipale également
notre camion aussi de la restauration
municipale et bien qui va au plus près
de nos seniors pour le portage de repas
à domicile donc si la situation était
amenée à durée et à s'en créer dans le
temps là on ferait face vraiment à des
difficultés pour lesquelles je crois on
n'a pas de solution miracle
malheureusement alors on va parler
d'électricité et du gaz l'autre
difficulté on en entend parler dans les
coursives de l'Université des mairies de
l'Ouest parisien cette se fait que
l'inflation en fait des prix de
l'énergie dans un rapport du Sénat l'AMF
l'Association des maires de France
estime une augmentation entre 30 et 300
% des prix de l'énergie concrètement
comment ça se gère là au quotidien en ce
moment parce que c'est que le début
alors moi plus particulièrement sur ma
ville aujourd'hui on a engagé un
processus de de communication avec
l'ensemble des usagers de nos structures
les associations l'ensemble des services
pour faire de la pédagogie tenter au
maximum de
limiter le chauffage l'électricité des
luminaires éteindre les PC le soir mais
justement ça tombe bien qu'on soit là
sur ce plateau aujourd'hui j'ai réuni
l'ensemble de mes dirigeants
d'associations ce soir salle des fêtes
de Gargenville pour leur annoncer à un
certain nombre de protocoles qui vont
être mis en place dorénavant dès demain
après après avoir partagé avec eux sur
leurs problématiques leurs besoins et
évidemment pour la continuité d'accueil
de nos enfants dans les structures
sportives mais néanmoins avec tout un
processus reconditionné pour minimiser
les coûts et les dépenses d'énergie donc
moi aujourd'hui je sais pas comment ça
va se passer je sais que peut être
compliqué pour certaines structure qui
vivent aussi en partie hein de leur
activité associative donc
c'est pour l'instant la seule démarche
que j'ai engagée au-delà de ça on a déjà
prévu que s'il est température venaient
à baisser
au-dessous les 5 degrés qu'on devrait
absolument fermer les structures au
regard des surcos qu'on subit déjà sa
hauteur de combien aujourd'hui à
Gargenville Gargenville j'ai les
chiffres sans la variable d'ajustement
de la température qui pour arriver en
hiver évidemment puisque
ça peut conditionner pas mal les
dépenses
sur l'échelle des quatre dernières
années je suis passé de 100000 euros à
800000 euros voilà donc multiplié par 8
par 8 comment ça se passe à Villepreux
niveau chiffre on est à peu près dans
les mêmes proportions avec surtout moi
l'évolution du prix du du gaz sur
l'année 2023 qui m'inquiète et on le
voit même pour l'électricité lorsqu'on
est dans des groupements comme le Sey où
on est quand même dans des logiques de
matchs utilisation ça nous protège pas
donc de vrais inquiétudes sur
des années qui arrivent
à Villepreux ça se passe je pense un peu
un peu de la même façon que dans les
autres communes d'abord je voudrais dire
que l'ensemble des communes sont
touchées mais qui a une strate qui l'est
tout particulièrement je dirais que
c'est la nôtre c'est celle des petites
villes j'ai la chance avec mon collègue
Daniel cornalba d'être référent de
l'Association des petites villes de
France dans les Yvelines et
l'association La PVF a été une des
premières alerté avant même le conflit
en Ukraine de cette hausse des tarifs de
l'énergie que nous allions subir
aujourd'hui là aussi on est en attente
je pense de mesures dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finance alors il y a
des petites choses qui ont été annoncées
mais quand on commence à creuser et à
regarder les différents critères
notamment sur le le pourcentage
d'autofinancement des recettes la
capacité d'autofinancement le potentiel
fiscal des habitants je rentre pas dans
les détails mais finalement les fameuses
30000 communes qui pourraient être
concernées par ce nouveau bouclier
tarifaire dit pour les collectivités on
n'est pas éligible donc très compliqué
comment ça se passe à Villepreux et ben
écoutez on a des on a décidé d'engager
un sobriété locale donc j'étais encore
lundi soir avec mes élus les directeurs
et les chefs de services pour décliner
de façon très opérationnelle ce plan ça
a été dit par mon collègue ça va
évidemment toucher la vie associative
puisque on a décidé de profiter de la
période des vacances pour repousser
aussi la période de chauffe de certains
bâtiments certains équipements sportifs
on a décidé là où il y avait quelques
créneaux à louer aux associations
pendant les vacances de pas les allouer
pour justement avoir des bâtiments qui
vont être fermés bon il y a des mesures
je rentre pas dans le détail de toutes
les mesures parce que je crois que
finalement on fait preuve de créativité
d'imaginerité mais on a finalement à peu
près tous ces mêmes la difficulté c'est
que quand on est et je pense que c'est
la
[Musique]
c'est le cas dans une grande majorité de
communes une fois un corps on est dans
des logiques d'optimisation depuis de
très nombreuses années ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les marges de manoeuvre
pour dégager de nouvelles pistes
d'économie elles sont réduites voire
quasi inexistantes donc aujourd'hui on
va devoir prendre des mesures d'urgence
des mesures immédiates je dirais que
c'est le volet nécessité de la sobriété
mais il va falloir aussi regarder vers
l'avant et là j'espère qu'on aura un
soutien à l'investissement puisqu'il
faudra aussi qu'on engage des travaux de
réhabilitation et de rénovation
énergétique de nos bâtiments puisque si
on veut faire sur le moyen et long terme
des économies il va falloir aussi qu'on
s'attaque à notre patrimoine bâti
justement on parlera des solutions après
Elisa coru vous vous êtes fournisseur
d'énergie qui travaillaient avec les
collectivités territoriales comment vous
pouvez accompagner les collectivités les
communes dans cette hausse des tarifs
sur la hausse des tarifs je crois qu'il
y a quelque chose de très important à
avoir en tête c'est que elle est liée à
des cotations et des cotations sur
lequel nous voilà en tant que
fournisseur d'énergie on n'a pas la main
donc il y a des places de marché c'est
vrai donc sur le pétrole c'est vrai sur
le gaz et sur l'électricité comme ça a
été justement dit la tension notamment
sur sur les prix à démarrer aussi avant
le conflit ukrainien parce que ben on a
une énergie nucléaire en France et que
il y avait il y a toujours d'ailleurs
des des réacteurs nucléaires à l'arrêt
qui déjà avaient induit une certaine une
certaine tension sur sur les prix donc
une extrême volabilité volatilité que
nous on subit évidemment il y a eu des
mesures avec la reine et donc nous
directement en tout cas on répercute ça
aussi c'est une on répercute directement
à nos clients toutes les mesures qui
sont prises pour les pour aider
justement assez assez l'énergie mais je
dirais que sur la dimension marché
l'autre engagement qu'on a pris on a
signé effectivement l'achat qui est de
dire que on remettra des prix puisque
aujourd'hui il y a quand même des
fournisseurs qui quand les contrats
arrivent à terme ne sont pas en mesure
de poursuivre ces contrats et donc de
remettre des nouvelles offres elles sont
ce qu'elles sont parce qu'on est
dépendant des marchés internationaux
mais en tout cas on a pris l'engagement
dans le dans le cadre de cette charme de
dire que si trois mois avant
effectivement lance la consultation la
consultation est lancée on remettra une
offre d'approvisionnement en énergie
donc ça c'est une première chose on
soutient évidemment toute la dimension
est éco-geste Ecowatt et je pense que là
on a aussi un enjeu fort comme le disait
Monsieur le Maire supéron mais de de
pédagogie donc ça c'est pour voilà
l'aspect accompagnement et relais sur
sur le territoire par rapport à ce qu'on
peut faire
si vous pouvez me permettre juste
aujourd'hui
vous parliez de plantes sobriété c'est
quelque chose qui avait déjà été engagé
au préalable de l'ensemble de ces crises
évidemment l'ensemble des mers sont
souvent des gestionnaires en bon père de
famille et toutes ces problématiques
étaient déjà engagées même par mes
prédécesseurs sur sur des logiques de
passage en éclairage LED des des
structures sportives qui sont fortement
consommatrices etc donc là aujourd'hui
on est même plus à traiter une
problématique de sobriété on traite une
urgence qui nous pousse à des solutions
drastiques de fermeture des structures
de de juste ne plus avoir la capacité de
payer nos propres consommations
d'énergie donc 20 pour ce qui me
concerne on en arrive à ces réflexions
là c'est de plus être en capacité
d'honorer nos factures comme des
peut-être des centaines de ménage aussi
des centaines de ménages en France en
fait finalement ce qui arrive aux
Français ça arrive aux communes en fait
à la fin du mois vous n'êtes pas en
capacité de payer votre facture
d'énergie et c'est ça et donc
aujourd'hui quelles sont les solutions
qui s'offrent à nous et d'ailleurs ça ne
veut dire que ça suffira mais
l'augmentation de la fiscalité locale
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
faire peser toujours sur les mêmes les
propriétaires et bien un effort
supplémentaire ça veut dire impacter le
portefeuille des Français qui sont déjà
concernés par la crise et vous venez de
le dire et je rejoins tout à fait mon
collègue alors la sobriété il y a des
mesures immédiates d'urgence au-delà de
tout ce qu'il y a déjà été engagé soit
par nos soins soit par nos prédécesseurs
et je rejoins totalement par exemple sur
les dépenses de personnel quand on nous
dit il faut continuer à réduire les
dépenses de personnel moi aujourd'hui
les dépenses de personnel ça fait des
années qu'elles ont été optimisées en
revanche il faut qu'on arrive à absorber
et c'est une très bonne mesure sociale
pour les agents mais le dégel du point
d'indice moi ça représente sur une année
à peu près 6 postes que je pourrais
créer donc c'est non négligeable donc il
y a ces mesures d'urgence
on a on a employé un terme avec diverses
associations d'élus et notamment la PVF
qui est celui d'un risque de blackout
territorial et ça ne renvoie pas
uniquement à l'éclairage ça renvoie à la
notion de fermeture de service public
parce que je crois que aujourd'hui quand
on ne peut pas payer à la fin de l'année
ou à la fin du mois nos factures c'est
évidemment la qualité de service et le
service public de nos territoires qui
est remis en question donc aujourd'hui
on en est à un point où dans les
arbitrages qu'on doit rendre au niveau
de nos collectivités au niveau de nos
maires c'est de savoir aussi où est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir dégager d'économie en
peut-être pas en fermant mais en
réduisant les plages horaires d'accueil
certaines prestations offertes par des
services on en est là aujourd'hui donc
on sait que de toute façon on va se
faire mal parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre
choix mais je peux vous assurer que
c'est pas agréable et que moi je suis
très inquiet sur l'avenir proche de nos
communes et puis derrière il y a des
humains aussi parce qu'il y a des
fonctionnaires aussi
donc c'est mettre en activité partielle
et les fonctionnaires pardon non parce
qu'il y a des il y a des il y a des
besoins je veux dire dans nos
collectivités il y a des besoins donc
moi c'est ce que je j'évoquais un
instant j'ai pas de marge de manœuvre
aujourd'hui sur le personnel communal
Jean-Baptiste parler d'un risque de
blackout territorial c'est à dire une
coupure de l'électricité faute de
paiement des factures est-ce que vous en
tout fournisseur d'énergie vous seriez
capable de couper finalement
l'électricité a des communes qui ne
payent pas leurs factures le la question
la question qui se pose c'est déjà nous
et la grosse enjeu qui avait c'était
est-ce qu'il y en aura si on parle du
gaz c'est est-ce que déjà il y aura
cette énergie de disponible parce que
vous avez raison on est toujours sur ces
contextes énergétiques avec
ces défis qui sont le prix la
disponibilité et puis
l'enjeu de tout terme mais également la
dimension carbone et climat et comment
faire voilà on est on est dans ce
triptyque donc la première chose c'était
la disponibilité et donc notre premier
enjeu c'était de se mettre voilà en
stock pour passer l'hiver et de se dire
que déjà il y en aura donc ça c'est
l'enjeu l'enjeu numéro 1 et puis ensuite
et bien il y a des décisions
effectivement politiques il y a pas mal
de discussion qui sont actuellement en
cours et donc on verra ce qui on verra
ce qui en sortir justement dans les
discussions politiques dont vous parlez
actuellement il y a le projet de loi de
finances qui est en discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale
il prévu notamment un plafonnement de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie à hauteur
de 15%, est-ce que ça c'est réalisable
de votre côté par rapport au fait que
vous aussi vous subissez une hausse
c'était pour ça que c'était important de
rappeler parce que beaucoup de gens se
disent les prix de l'énergie augmentent
c'est que on augmente
le distributeur augmente ses marges non
donc c'est pour ça que je rappelais
effectivement ce cette dimension là je
pense que il est en tout cas à notre
niveau mais on voilà ce qu'il y a des
discussions politiques qui sont il y a
des décisions qui seront prises et on va
on verra bien aujourd'hui ça se voilà on
ne sait pas quels sont les décisions
donc c'est un peu tôt pour parler
peut-être pour rebondir là dessus parce
que c'est l'une des demandes avec
l'indexation de de la DGF sur
l'inflation évidemment même si on sait
qu'on a peu de chance de l'obtenir on on
a ce sujet du bouclier tarifaire et
aujourd'hui quand on regarde évidemment
les acteurs concernés par le bouclier
tarifaire il y a un grand absence sont
quand même les collectivités locales le
bouclier tarifaire aujourd'hui c'est un
amortisseur pour les entreprises pour
les particuliers alors il y a dans les
discussions notamment sur le sur le PLF
des petites choses qui ont été annoncées
pour un certain nombre de communes mais
je je pense que chaque mère est en train
de regarder à l'heure actuelle en tout
cas le fera d'ici à ce soir les
différents critères qui ont été posés et
on verra que on est loin du compte et
que la majorité des communes
malheureusement ne sont pas illigibles à
ce nouveau dispositif avant de vous
faire réagir à une perront je pense que
Martha que la sénatrice des a entendu
parler du projet de loi de finance et on
l'accueille sur notre plateau beau jour
on l'accueille sur d'autres plateaux
donc on parlait justement du projet loi
de finance et notamment des mesures qui
étaient en cours de discussion au
Parlement c'est pas encore au Sénat mais
bientôt vous allez pouvoir en discuter
de ce texte donc des mesures pour
soutenir les collectivités terriales
face à l'inflation des prix d'énergie
juste Yann perron avant de vous faire
réagir justement Martin drague sur ce
sujet donc vous qu'est-ce qu'elle
regarde vous avez sur ces mesures qui
sont en cours de discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale on parle de la
hausse de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement on parle du plafonnement
des prix de l'énergie ou encore des
aides de l'État qui serait prolongée
comme la bien dit mon confrère
aujourd'hui on peut croire que ce qu'on
voit dans tous les cas aujourd'hui c'est
en discussion évidemment la DGF ont subi
des baisses drastiques depuis tant
d'années qu'on a pu trop d'espoir pour
le reste le bouclier tarifaire pour les
municipalités et l'ensemble des
collectivités on l'attend évidemment
puisque comme on vient de le dire c'est
un traitement dans l'urgence d'une
problématique qui nous pousse tous à à
interpréter ça de manière un peu un peu
le gosse pour nos administrer et on a
également tous peur
des conséquences de tout ça à la fois
sur nos agents mais sur nos administrés
oui puisque faut dire quand même qu'il y
a un bouclier qui a été voté un filet de
sécurité voté lors d'un projet de loi de
finance rectificatif cet été et qui
prévoyait des communes mais finalement
il y a 5000 communes qui ont été aidés
grâce à ce dispositif Martin drague
justement vous qui allez alors je sais
que vous n'êtes pas directement
concernés parce que vous n'êtes pas dans
cette commission finance au Sénat mais
forcément vous êtes impacté par ce sujet
vous êtes sûrement interpellé par des
maires aujourd'hui ici justement alors
c'est le sujet numéro un lorsque l'on va
à la rencontre de nos élus locaux et des
mers évidemment
c'est le sujet numéro un aujourd'hui
puisque je vais vous donner juste un
élément de contexte aujourd'hui au
niveau des budgets des communes le
budget concernant les énergies a déjà
été utilisée en fait alors que fin
juillet les communes avaient déjà
utilisé le monde du budget qui était
alloué en réalité à leur poste
énergétique cela signifie qu'en fait il
va falloir tenir jusqu'à la fin de
l'année je me tourne vers un maire qui
est juste à mes côtés et
évidemment cela va poser de grosses
difficultés cela veut dire aussi pour
nos élus locaux des arbitrages difficile
à faire puisque tout est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui soumis à une augmentation je
pense aussi à nos petits écoliers la
restauration scolaire par exemple la
fourniture des matières premières enfin
tout est à l'avenant donc effectivement
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous au Sénat
on va se pencher avec beaucoup
d'attention pour pouvoir soutenir au
mieux nos communes
est-ce que aujourd'hui déjà vous êtes
dans l'anticipation alors vous êtes déjà
dans l'anticipation mais est-ce que
aujourd'hui vous posez la question on va
fermer tel service on va fermer tel
bureau
partiellement on va dire je pense qu'il
en est pas jusque là comme je vous l'ai
dit précédemment voilà les arbitrages
sont faits quant à la logique de
fermeture des structures sur des
températures qui pourraient venir à
baisser à des niveaux
inférieurs à ce qu'on a évidemment en ce
moment au-delà de ça ça risque d'être
tellement douloureux que je préfère pas
imaginer la réaction épidermique de
l'ensemble de nos administrés sur la
totalité du territoire parce que c'est
pas seulement sur l'ensemble de nos
villes et les traitements
on va dire particuliers de nos
problématiques c'est une là on
rentrerait dans une problématique
tellement générale que je pense que
c'est les services de l'État qui
devraient intervenir très rapidement
pour pour protéger tout le monde
oui on est sur le point de rendre des
arbitrages douloureux certains
équipements qu'on sera peut-être amenés
à affirmer sur une année blanche je
pense notamment à notre théâtre
municipal alors que qui est un
équipement qui vivote déjà depuis un
moment et sur lequel on était en
réflexion pour trouver un nouveau projet
pour que ce soit un bâtiment et une
offre culturelle pérenne mais au regard
évidemment du contexte ça va être
compliqué de lancer quelque chose cette
année autre équipement qui fait l'objet
de discussion au sein de l'équipe
municipale c'est évidemment notre
piscine alors c'est pas une piscine qui
ouverte à l'année c'est une piscine sur
la saison estivale de moi juillet-août
sauf que pour mettre un petit billet
d'investissement chaque année parce
qu'il y a quelques petits travaux
toujours à faire pour ouvrir le bassin
dans de bonnes conditions qu'il faut
très tôt et bien engagé des dépenses de
fonctionnement notamment sur le
personnel puisqu'il faut recruter des
chefs de bassin qui sont d'ailleurs des
denrées de plus en plus rares Martin
Sidrac est voté évoqué pardon aussi la
restauration je délibère lundi prochain
en conseil mun global sur un
renouvellement de marché évidemment qui
va être à la hausse après déjà des
avenants de régularisation ces derniers
mois de l'ordre de deux fois 7 % 14 %.
donc oui on a des coûts du service
public qui augmente et on est forcé
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure malheureusement de de nous
faire mal parce que dans les arbitrages
à rendre il y aura rien de eux il y aura
malheureusement rien heureux mais il
faut à la fois passer l'hiver et essayer
de voir comment on va pouvoir se
projeter le plus sereinement possible
sur les prochains mois
et je crois qu'on est arrivé dans un tel
processus de rejet de la fiscalité que
en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne je
ne partirai pas sur des arbitrages qui
sont propres à augmenter la fiscalité on
diminuera les services on diminuera les
services
jusqu'au de la conserver ce qui est
indispensable mais voilà tout ce qui
concerne les parties loisirs seront
certainement très fortement impactés
mais en tout cas le levier fiscal n'est
aujourd'hui plus acceptable avant de
parler de fiscalité avec martinac un mot
ils accueil Comment qu'est-ce qu'attend
total énergie en tant que fourniture
d'énergie qu'est-ce qu'il attend de
l'État en fait par rapport à ce sujet là
est-ce qu'il y a des attentes
particulières de l'État plus
d'accompagnement pour les communes
justement pour éviter ce genre de
phénomène
on a voilà moi je suis pas en mesure de
voilà de prendre position et sur sur des
décisions des décisions d'État tout ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que nous on l'a
prouvé au travers de ce qu'on a pu faire
pour le carburant et l'aide au pouvoir
d'achat là on parle effectivement le sur
le marché des particuliers on a
également fait un certain nombre de de
mesures d'accompagnement voilà donc on a
montré et et on est bien évidemment très
soucieux de de de du quotidien
des Français de tout ce qui a été dit là
donc voilà et puis pour le pour pour la
suite en tout cas on est aussi on a on
attend les décisions qui qui vont être
prises le projet loi de finance n'est
pas voté finalement ça vous avez pas de
visibilité sur sur le comment ça peut
évoluer Martin sida qu'on parlait de
fiscalité justement
qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous
qu'est-ce que vous pourriez proposer
comme mesure fiscale ou comme mesure
d'aide au Sénat par rapport à au projet
de loi de finances mais écoutez pour
l'instant on va voir quel sera le texte
définitif qui va arriver chez nous donc
il va arriver ces jours prochains nous
sommes on est tous les sénateurs
l'ensemble quel que soit le groupe
politique auquel on appartient nous
discutons avec notre rapporteur général
puisque il y a aussi au sein même de la
maison Sénat si je peux le dire comme ça
un débat qui se qui est suscité autour
d'un sujet qui est éminemment important
et comme le territoire ont tous aussi
leur spécificité leur propre choix à
faire par exemple nous avons des élus
qui parlent de la taxe foncière a
augmenté par augmenter qu'est-ce qu'on
fait etc comme on abonde qui va payer
est-ce que c'est l'usager ce constat
toujours vers le contribuable est-ce que
on augmente tous les tarifs il y a un
certain nombre de sujets qui ne sont pas
perçus avec la même acuité selon le
territoire dans lequel on se trouve donc
aujourd'hui moi je ne peux pas parler
pour le Sénat puisque nous ne sommes pas
encore véritablement en examen
approfondie du texte pour vous donner
les grandes lignes qui vont se dégager
chez nous en tout cas une chose est
certaine c'est que on va s'y atteler de
façon très sérieuse on n'est pas dans
une comme ça peut s'entendre ici et là
dans une opposition pour dire le budget
va pas donc on va pas aller on va pas
faire de propositions nous sommes en
fait dans une démarche constructive
parce que nous sommes conscients qu'il
faut soutenir nos communes et nos
collectivités et qui va falloir qu'on
travaille avec vous tous pour trouver la
meilleure articulation qui sera je
dirais la moins mauvaise réponse il n'y
en aura pas de bonne vous l'avez dit
tous les deux ce seront ce seront des
choix que il faudra que nous fassions
collectivement et à un moment donné il
faut que ces choix-là nous puissions les
expliquer collectivement à l'ensemble de
nos administrés quel que soit le
territoire alors vous parliez des
décisions urgentes à prendre vous avez
fait aussi mention de la rénovation des
bâtiments publics et notamment pour les
améliorer au niveau énergétique on va
basculer sur l'autre thématique la
thématique de l'environnement c'est
forcément lié et on va commencer avec
vous et Lisa Queru parce que il y a un
projet que vous venez de présenter à
Gargenville dans la raffinerie de de
Gargenville qui bascule centrale solaire
avec des panneaux photovoltaïques et que
qui a été inauguré du coup dans votre
commune alors d'abord présenté ce projet
et puis voir quel impact ça peut avoir
aussi sur les bâtiments publics oui je
crois que comme vous le dites plus que
jamais avec la crise que nous vivons on
voit l'importance de la territorialité
l'énergie et de rotoraux territorialisée
l'énergie de l'énergie renouvelable et
que là en effet la place des
collectivités et la manière dont on
optimise le foncier pour produire des
énergies renouvelables et déterminante
et donc en effet à Gargenville on vient
d'inaugurer la plus grande centrale
solaire d'Île-de-France sur un foncier
parce que on transforme nos activités
pétrolières parce qu'on a l'ambition
d'être neutre en carbone en 2050 et est
un acteur majeur de la transition
énergétique avec moins de pétrole et
plus d'énergie renouvelables et
notamment électriques et donc ça se voit
sur nos sites donc on transforme la
raffinée de Grand Prix en site zéro
pétrole et le dépôt de Gargenville
associé et bien le foncier disponible on
le convertit en centrale photovoltaïque
et demain en carburant pour l'aviation
durable et en fait on a inauguré la
semaine dernière 24 hectares plus de
53000 panneaux photovoltaïques est-ce
que cette énergie qui va être produite
sur va bénéficier justement aux
habitants de Gargenville mais aussi au
bâtiment public non pas pas directement
malheureusement c'est très dommage mais
non en tout cas ça bénéficie à ma ville
en terme d'image déjà pour pour
commencer parce que c'est la
valorisation d'un d'un site de raffinage
en production des énergies renouvelable
et particulièrement profitable à la fois
pour l'image de Total mais aussi pour
l'image de ma ville qui s'est totalement
désindustrialisé sur ces 35 années à la
fois pour le raffinage de pétrole la
production de ciment et j'en passe
encore donc évidemment le renouveau et
la réaffectation de ces sites qui sont
dans tous les cas
pour plus ou moins pollués ou dans tous
les cas impossible à réhabiliter en
termes d'habitation et et est important
et je crois que sur l'ensemble de la
vallée de scène puisque c'est un autre
sujet qui me concerne particulièrement
sur ma délégation de vice-président de
la Communauté Urbaine GPSO
l'ensemble des des friches industrielles
qui qui sont sur l'ensemble de l'axe
scène entre le Grand Paris et Le Havre
seront bien évidemment toute ciblées à
la production d'énergie renouvelable
dans un futur très proche puisque c'est
une nécessité absolue pour notre pays de
trouver l'indépendance énergétique et un
projet bioéthanie de méthanisation aussi
tout à fait exactement un projet de
méthane que j'ai initié avec la
précédente directrice du site puisque
évidemment la proposition totale c'était
d'optimiser au maximum l'utilisation de
son foncier
il en reste un petit peu la
biométhanisation est aujourd'hui
un des facteurs un des potentiels de de
production d'énergie qui nous reste sur
le territoire puisque la loi la loi
egalim va nous imposer de traiter
l'ensemble des matières organiques qui
sont générés dans nos infrastructures et
pour l'ensemble des particuliers dans un
second temps donc évidemment la
ressource en énergie et en matière
organique elle est là il faut la
valoriser au mieux sur des unités
proches
de nos territoires proches de générateur
de déchets et on a tout intérêt à
apprendre tout de suite tout de suite le
levier de cette démarche elisaquerez
être obligé de nous quitter dans
quelques instants pour des obligations
juste pour sur ce projet de de
méthanisation est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus vous quel rôle
vous allez jouer mais aujourd'hui total
énergie on est leader en biogaz en
France et comme vous l'avez dit sur les
solutions long terme il y a une fête de
réinventer l'énergie aux bornes des
territoires et ça touche aussi au modèle
on prenait l'exemple du photovoltaïque
tout à l'heure où la ou de la
méthanisation là mais sur le
photovoltaïque typiquement sur les modes
de financement il faut savoir que nous
on est là aussi pour accompagner les
collectivités avec différents types de
solutions les partenariats où on va
aller finalement être en montée au
capital alors soit avec des
collectivités elle est actuellement les
discussions sont avec des syndicats
d'énergie pour justement permettre aux
collectivités d'avoir des projets plus
gros ça c'est une chose on a aussi la
possibilité d'avoir de
l'autoconsommation collective avec un
foncier disponible dans le côté et puis
des collectivités qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier justement de la production
photovoltaïque de localement produite en
direct donc on voit bien que l'univers
de l'énergie est en train de se
réinventer et qu'il y a plusieurs
modèles et donc peut-être pour dire en
tout cas nous ce qu'on souhaite apporter
et aux collectivités c'est vraiment
d'être justement à leur côté et d'être
en temps réel pouvoir échanger ensemble
sur toutes les solutions qui s'offrent à
nous et toutes les mutations qui sont en
cours dans le cadre de cette transition
énergétique et qui ouvre aussi la voie à
des nouveaux modèles et des nouveaux
modèles de rémunération qui peuvent
aussi aider les collectivités dans leur
transition énergétique merci Yann en
tout cas pour pour abonder dans le dans
le discours d'Elisa je tiens vraiment à
dire que total et en totale
transparent sur sur ses actions
participent et en communication
continuelle avec les les services de ma
ville et c'est plutôt agréable de
développer ce type de projet avec une
entreprise qui est totalement à l'écoute
des attentes des élus alors Elisa Curie
merci d'avoir participé à cette émission
je rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
régionale de Total énergie en
Île-de-France dans quelques minutes on
va accueillir Guillaume Pasquier qui est
directeur du développement du groupe ect
une entreprise spécialisée dans la
revalorisation des terres utilisées
notamment sur les chantiers du BTP donc
je rappelle on est en édition spéciale
sur l'université des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien on parle d'énergie on a basculé
sur la thématique de l'environnement et
justement cette question à vous
Jean-Baptiste Amélie qui est Martin drag
que les énergies renouvelables peuvent
être une solution face à cette inflation
face aussi à justement la gestion des
énergies au niveau des communes au
niveau des collectivités
oui évidemment après je dirais qu'on est
aujourd'hui je prendrais peut-être
l'exemple des transports qui est un
domaine du coup que je j'ai l'occasion
de de côtoyer au quotidien en tant que
VP transport de l'agglote vous êtes
vice-président au mobilité oui on
parlait des mesures d'urgence des
mesures de court terme la sobriété c'est
pas non plus l'austérité donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut continuer à investir
évidemment pour l'avenir et donc ça
passera dans cette volonté que nous
avons d'avoir une transition énergétique
et bien sur des investissements on a
parlé de nos bâtiments publics moi je
m'arrête 5 minutes sur le domaine des
transports et notamment des transports
en commun mais pas uniquement je dirais
que je suis assez inquiet et maintenant
on est dans une période de flou puisque
on en est à se poser la question
finalement quelle est la bonne énergie
puisque on le voit là aujourd'hui en
période de de crise du carburant on
savait que le carburant est notamment le
moteur thermique allait pas être
l'avenir de la mobilité bon aujourd'hui
le véhicule électrique à l'heure où la
dépense d'électricité les dépenses
augmentent on peut aussi se poser la
question je rentre pas dans le débat des
batteries du recyclage etc des sujets
d'indépendance aussi que cela suppose
l'hydrogène malheureusement reste encore
assez peu concurrentiel dans le sens où
le coup rester élevé donc de vrais
interrogations sur finalement comment
avancer sur sur cette question nous on a
décidé si je prends l'exemple 50 chinois
et je sais que c'est partagé Paris le
France mobilité qui d'ailleurs à
quelques petits sujets quand même
budgétaires et financier au passage on
sait que c'est pas loin d'un milliard
que Île-de-France mobilité recherche
pour boucler le budget 2023 on verra
comment cela se traduit notamment pour
les usagers sur le Pass Navigo je
referme la parenthèse
je pense qu'il faut surtout pas mettre
tous nos œufs dans le même panier et
c'est pour ça que je lance une alerte
aussi sur l'électrique pour ce qui
concerne les transports la mobilité
électrique je pense qu'elle a toute sa
place mais attention à ne pas recréer
l'erreur je pense qu'on a pu faire avec
le diesel donc il faut vraiment qu'on
soit vigilant là-dessus il faut aussi je
pense relever le défi des transports en
commun puisque on est encore en période
de convalescence post covid que là on a
maintenant cette crise énergétique on a
à peu près 30% des usagers qui ne sont
pas revenus aujourd'hui dans les
transports en commun donc forcément
c'est un impact mais néanmoins pourquoi
je citer le France mobilité parce que je
pense que Île de France mobilité a
néanmoins raison de continuer à investir
sur son réseau et raison avec l'ensemble
des partenaires et des autorités
organisatrices et bien de
d'aborder des nouvelles solutions en
termes d'énergie renouvelable il n'y a
pas de solution miracle moi je pense
qu'il faut essayer d'aller sur
l'ensemble du champ des possibles des
énergies qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
sur la table et je pense que en tout cas
le contexte actuel montre à quel point
nous avons raison dans ce pays de ne pas
abandonner le nucléaire Martha tidrac
sur ce sujet des énergies renouvelables
vous qui connaissez très bien le sujet
puisque je rappelle que vous avez
contribué assez largement vous étiez
rapporteur sur le texte de loi la loi
AGEC la lutte la loi relative à la lutte
contre le gaspillage et l'économie
circulaire
oui tout à fait alors bien évidemment
l'énergie aujourd'hui nous préoccupe
tous énormément au Sénat ça fait
quelques temps déjà nous souhaitons
avoir un grand débat sur l'énergie dans
son ensemble c'est à dire quel est notre
vision ça rejoint un petit peu les
propos aussi qui vient d'être dit parce
que il nous semble qu'il ne faut
absolument pas opposer une énergie par
rapport à une autre énergie chacune en
réalité des sources que ce soit en
matière d'approvisionnement en termes
d'impact environnemental en termes de je
dirais de cycle de vie dans son ensemble
à des avantages et des inconvénients la
question qui se pose à nous aujourd'hui
collectivement au-delà du contexte un
peu particulier évidemment on pense tous
à la guerre en Ukraine on pense tous à
un certain nombre de prix la flambée des
prix sur l'énergie mais je crois qu'il
faut garder aussi son sang-froid
là-dessus il y va de la vision que nous
avons nous dans notre pays sur ce que
doit être demain l'approvisionnement
énergétique de la
[Musique]
même pas opposer les énergies
véritablement se poser la question de ce
qui peut-être bon ou pas bon pour nous
sur l'ensemble des volets et
à cette étape je conclurai là-dessus
nous allons avoir le grand texte de loi
sur les énergies renouvelables qui est
annoncée qui va arriver chez nous tout
début novembre donc sur lequel il va
falloir aussi nous prononcer mais là
encore vous voyez on va encore être pour
contre on va essayer d'adapter enrichir
le texte mais en réalité le débat
réellement demandé depuis très longtemps
au Sénat sur ce que doit être notre
politique énergétique de la France nous
fait encore un petit peu défaut si j'ai
un regret pour moi il est là alors si on
va au-delà de la politique énergétique
on va parler plus globalement de
l'environnement et des pratiques
environnementales notamment au niveau de
vos communes au niveau de la loi que
vous avez sur laquelle vous avez
travaillé on va parler aussi de cette
thématique avec le groupe ect Guillaume
Pasquet nous a rejoint bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le connecteurs du
développement de cette entreprise déjà
brièvement une présentation de cette
société spécialisée dans la valorisation
des terres c'est ça exactement et bien
nous sommes nous sommes un acteur pure
player de l'économie circulaire puisque
notre métier consiste à renaturer des
sites en utilisant comme matière
première les terres escavées des
chantiers alentours donc nous utilisons
pour recréer des espaces verts de
qualité qui peuvent être d'une large
gamme équipement sportif agriculture de
proximité parc pour les communes nous
utilisons pour faire cela les terres qui
qui sortent et qui sont une gêne qui
sont un encombrement pour les les
acteurs de la construction alentours qui
doivent donc leur trouver un exutoire
une solution juridiquement ces terres
sont des déchets alors bien entendu la
terre n'est pas un déchet mais
juridiquement elle prend ce statut quand
elle sort d'une emprise notre métier à
nous c'est de quoi concevoir avec les
élus et les propriétaires des projets de
qualité sur des sites généralement
dégradés pour que CTR viennent à cet
endroit là
refasse un nouveau mot de lait adapté
aux
vous êtes concerné par ce genre de
discours et puis en globalement sur la
les pratiques environnementales à
Gargenville comment vous travaillez vous
en tant que cellule locaux
alors les problématiques
environnementales c'est un terme large
c'est vraiment très largeur on parle
nous des problématiques
environnementales sur le traitement des
espaces publics après plus largement
avec les industriels les PPRT enfin vous
voyez on passe vraiment sur des
dimensions qui sont totalement opposées
moi les problématiques rien que sur les
espaces publics aujourd'hui je suis
parti sur une logique
de traitement des espaces publics le
moins possible le le traiter le moins
possible on ne tombe plus on fait de la
tonte différenciée sur l'ensemble des
espaces on laisse la nature un petit peu
reprendre sa place et arriver la fin de
l'été on remet un coup de propre général
et c'est reparti pour les 6 mois d'hiver
donc ça ça a été politiquement difficile
à à soutenir
je pense que l'acceptabilité au fur et à
mesure des générations va être de plus
en plus facile mais néanmoins c'est un
petit peu difficile pour l'ensemble des
maires de laisser partir les espaces
publics un petit peu soi-disant se
dégrader mais quand on voit des
pissenlits poussés dans les dans les
bordures de trottoir c'est pas
particulièrement ça en soit mais c'est
des habitudes qui sont aujourd'hui
perdus pour l'ensemble de nos
administrés les problématiques vont
augmenter je les ai également sur le
traitement des des au niveau des
industriels on l'a vu avec total avec
qui ça se passe très bien on a aussi une
cimenterie à Gargenville qui qui a qui a
fermé qui a fermé son four de production
de ciment en décembre dernier donc on va
dire que les problématiques
environnementales entendant à
s'amenuiser sur mon territoire et que
les rapports néanmoins entre les
différents opérateurs industriels sont
plutôt courtois et les échanges assez
assez transparents donc j'ai pas
aujourd'hui de soucis particulier sur
les problématiques environnementales
Jean-Baptiste alors d'abord peut-être en
tant que mère mais aussi ensuite avec
votre casquette de vice-président en
charge des transports parce que
dernièrement à 50 ans en Yvelines vous
avez fait un programme de mobilité au
top 12 avec le vélo notamment tout à
fait alors
n'ayant ni zone industrielle ni free
industrielle ni foncier je suis la
campagne voilà moi je suis à 75% en
territoire naturel
site classé de la plaine de Versailles
périmètre ABS je suis pas évidemment sur
les mêmes les mêmes enjeux mais
néanmoins j'ai un enjeu sur mes
bâtiments publics je partage dans ce
qu'elle était dit sur l'entretien et les
bonnes pratiques sur les espaces verts
donc j'y reviens pas on a lancé au début
du mandat ne dites patrimonial et
énergétique sur l'ensemble de nos
bâtiments une cinquantaine de bâtiments
ce qu'il en ressort c'est qu'aujourd'hui
si on veut faire le minimum syndical de
travaux de réhabilitation et de
rénovation énergétique il faut sortir à
peu près 10 millions d'euros j'ai beau
regardé dans toutes mes poches
aujourd'hui je les ai pas donc je suis
plutôt je dirais
perceptif à l'idée que le gouvernement
est annoncé un plan vert doté d'un
milliard d'un milliard et 500000 alors
apparemment il passerait à 2 milliards
j'ai vu ça néanmoins si je vous dis que
moi sur la commune de Villepreux il me
faut 10 millions vous rapportez
l'enveloppe d'un milliard 5 ou 2
milliards à l'ensemble du territoire
national en y incluant les outre-mer
évidemment on va pas dire que ça soit
une enveloppe d'accompagnement
l'investissement qui sera nécessaire
pourquoi je j'aborde ce point c'est
parce que encore une fois et je relis ça
à notre discussion de départ sur
l'énergie les vrais économies
substantielles qu'on pourra réaliser ce
sera justement si on arrive à engager
des travaux de réhabilitation et de
rénovation énergétique et pour le faire
on a besoin d'être accompagné alors on
les parle département on les parle à la
région on l'est un petit peu par l'État
mais on en est toujours au même point en
tout cas je crois que c'est parti ça
sera partagé par mon collègue pour les
communes de notre strat c'est que
finalement les dispositifs qui sont
pensés élaborés par l'État et ses
services on se rend compte assez
rapidement que nous ne sommes pas
réellement éligibles et aujourd'hui si
vous êtes la commune avec tout le
respect que j'ai pensé comme une
évidemment mais en quartier prioritaire
ou en ruralité très profonde finalement
on n'a pas les bons dispositifs on nous
accompagner donc c'est très difficile de
faire avancer
j'allais dire cette thématique
importante de développement durable de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
sur la partie énergétique puisque ça
demande des investissements lourds et là
je pense que il faut que le vrai message
envoyé par l'État se situe justement sur
ce cet accompagnement en investissement
sur la partie mobilité je vais m'arrêter
plutôt sur l'immobilité durable
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on le
sanitaire de vélo et pas uniquement
parce qu'on aura le plaisir d'ici deux
ans d'accueillir sur quatre sites
olympiques des disciplines liées au vélo
je pense qu'il y a les championnats du
monde qui commence ce championnats du
monde aujourd'hui on aura le plaisir
d'accueillir celles et ceux qui veulent
venir voir comment ça se passe sur la
piste le Tour de France aussi l'année
prochaine qui partira du Vélodrome enfin
bon on a une terre de vélo sportive
l'idée et l'ambition que nous portons
c'est d'avoir une terre de vélo pour la
mobilité du quotidien et donc c'est
passé par un plan un schéma un lecteur
cyclable de 36 millions d'euros sur 10
ans ça a été adopté en décembre dernier
concrètement au-delà des 420 km
d'itinéraire cyclables que nous avons
déjà sur l'agglomération nous allons
décider d'en créer ou d'en rénover dans
d'améliorer 246 nouveaux en créant du
stationnement puisqu'on sait que le
stationnement la sécurité aussi des
biens donc des vélos mais des personnes
étant d'argument pour pouvoir avoir un
report model intéressant l'objectif qui
est le nôtre c'est de passer d'une part
model vélo de 3 à 8% d'ici 10 ans avec
un maillage de l'ensemble des douze
communes de l'agglomération je sais
qu'il y a le département aussi qui
déploie son plan vélo il y a la région
qui a le son RER vélo avec deux axes qui
vont venir notamment irriguer notre
agglomération donc je dirais que il y a
un alignement quelque part des planètes
parce que tous les acteurs même l'État a
annoncé son plan vélo ça a été annoncé
par la première ministre ont pris
conscience que aujourd'hui la mobilité
douce les modes actifs que sont le vélo
mais aussi les trottinettes je vois que
les trottinettes je le vois avec
beaucoup de bonheur à 50 ans ça
fonctionne bien aussi un peu partout
puisque d'autres collectivités ont
décidé de nous emboîter le pas
et bien évidemment voilà aujourd'hui on
sent qu'il y a un élan il faut
l'accompagner attention je reviens à mon
propos tout à l'heure sur les transports
en commun
les opposer c'est la même chose que les
que les énergies et de toute façon c'est
pas la mobilité durable qui permettra de
résoudre tous les problèmes de de
déplacement notamment dans notre
département où la voiture règne encore
en mettre on va conclure sur sur la loi
âgée qui est l'économie circulaire on va
revenir avec vous aussi pour savoir si
vous êtes saisis déjà de ces notions de
la loi agg et justement on a l'une des
actrices de cette loi déjà rappeler
quelques principes de cette loi votée en
2021 c'est ça 2010 en fait elle a été
promulguée le 10 février 2000 2020
pardon 2020
j'étais pas encore élu à ce moment-là
donc 2020 le 10 février et c'est une loi
en réalité qui aborde différents aspects
de l'économie circulaire
dans les territoires on voit d'ailleurs
j'ai fait beaucoup de déplacements là
dessus
quelque chose dont ce sont déjà saisi
beaucoup d'élus ce sont en fait la lutte
contre les dépôts sauvages puisque la
loi AGEC a introduit un certain nombre
de dispositifs et de mesure des outils
pour les élus locaux en termes de que ce
soit de le flagrant délit la
l'utilisation des caméras voilà il y a
en fait tout un toute une série
là-dessus il y a aussi évidemment le
sujet qui était autour de l'information
des consommateurs donc on a eu là qui
était beaucoup plus à destination de nos
administrés dans les communes donc il y
a déjà des beaucoup de ces mesures qui
sont en réalité aujourd'hui
appliquée qui sont rentrés en vigueur il
y a vous avez tout à l'heure évoqué le
sujet des déchets des bio déchets en
fait qui va venir en application donc
prochainement et puis je par un point
qui est très important qui est celui de
la création d'un certain nombre de
réponsabilité élargi du producteur dont
l'arrêt bâtiment qui est en lien aussi
avec les dépôts sauvages dans nos
territoires qui va permettre en réalité
un déploiement d'un certain nombre de
déchetteries dans le territoire avec des
éco-organismes qui accompagneront nos
collectivités de manière à permettre
d'aller dans le sens de la résorption de
ce fléau qui est véritablement national
y compris dans nos territoires
ultramarins Jean-Baptiste amonic a
évoqué aussi nos autres mères tout à
l'heure donc c'est une loi qui est pour
moi je le dis en fait avec beaucoup de
simplicité qui est très technique qui
est assez complet puisque il faut se
rappeler que le projet de loi lorsqu'il
est arrivé en première lecture au Sénat
comportait très articles il est sorti du
Sénat avec 103 articles et aujourd'hui
la loi fait 130 articles donc vous voyez
on voit que le Parlement a totalement
fait son job je le dis très très
simplement et a été enrichi beaucoup par
les parlementaires parce que ben parce
que par définition nous sommes proches
des territoires avec nos élus locaux et
beaucoup de ces inspirations nous
viennent directement de de des
territoires et de ce que l'on vit au
quotidien parce que c'est une véritable
opportunité cette loi pour vous oui tout
à fait oui tout à fait je rebondis sur
le le sujet des déchets sauvages parce
que pour nous c'est un double problème
la décharge sauvage la décharge d'abord
c'est un problème parce que c'est une
concurrence déloyale c'est-à-dire ce
sont des gens qui font qui qui nous
prennent nos clients en ne supportant
pas du tout les coups qu'on supporte
puisqu'ils n'ont pas la garantie
environnementale sur les sites qui
travaillent ils n'ont pas la garantie
traçabilité que nous mettons en oeuvre
pour s'assurer que toute terre qui vient
sur nos sites à nous soit bien de la
terre inerte et soit bien tracé sur
toutes les étapes de ce déplacement pour
qu'elles ne dégrade rien
milieu d'accueil donc forcément
premièrement
concurrence déloyale et puis
deuxièmement ça revient à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure ça donne une
mauvaise image de notre métier puisque
ça crée ça crée dans les dans les
esprits en particulier auprès de vos
administrés messieurs l'idée que un lieu
de stockage de terre n'est pas sain
n'est pas propre n'est pas contrôlé
n'est pas maîtrisé donc lutter contre
les déchets chômage ça pour nous c'est
effectivement essentiel ça va faciliter
notre travail grandement j'ajoute sur
les déchets sauvages d'un autre type
celle qui celle qui sont créées sur des
d'autres matériaux typiquement des
chaînes démolition ou alors on a tout vu
l'électroménager etc tout est possible
il nous est arrivé vous parliez tout à
l'heure de sollicitations et on a un
projet en cours en ce moment dans le
Val-d'Oise d'être sollicité pour par des
élus locaux qui avaient été confrontés à
cette problématique à une grande échelle
et qu'ils étaient incapables vu le
budget de la commune de la traiter
elle-même et l'agriculteur propriétaire
encore moins et donc ils nous ont
sollicité pour dire est-ce que avec
votre modèle vous êtes capable de mettre
de financer le la mise en décharge la
mise en filière de ces déchets puis de
recréer un sol de qualité avec de la
terreinière propre puis de le rendre à
l'agriculture alors l'équation ne tourne
pas toujours parfois on y arrive et dans
le Val d'Oise à bois s'il est le riz on
a réussi à le faire Martha oui et je
rajouterais aussi quelque chose qu'il
faut absolument comprendre dans la
volonté du législateur à travers cette
loi à Jacques c'est de dire à un moment
donné que les déchets ont de la valeur
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
dans vos propos liminaires quand vous
disiez bon parler de déchets c'est pas
très glamour moi souvent pour plaisanter
je dis je suis Madame déchet en fait je
m'occupe en réalité quand on parle
d'économie circulaire au fond c'est quoi
c'est de dire comment est-ce que on
réinjecte dans notre économie ce que
sont nos déchets aujourd'hui et on l'a
vu le covid est passé par là avec le sur
emballage les emballages etc à un moment
donné cela nous a posé des questions
aussi comment est-ce que après voilà
donc le déchet aujourd'hui c'est une
ressource en fait c'est ça la
philosophie première c'est ça qui font
intégrer on parle maintenant d'économie
circulaire puisque selon le type de
déchets le déchet va avoir plus ou moins
de valeur et va avoir plus ou moins la
bonne filière mise en place c'est tout
l'objet des reps pour j'essaie d'être
simple parce que c'est assez technique
en en fait et à travers si vous voulez
l'exutoire que l'on va trouver pour
chacun de nos déchets que ce soit le
textile que ce soit le plastique que ce
soit les déchets bâtiments à un moment
donné cela il va falloir le traiter
est-ce qu'on le est-ce qu'on l'aurait
emploie est-ce qu'on l'aurait utilise
est-ce qu'on le recycle est-ce qu'on
l'incinère est-ce qu'on le valorise en
CSR etc donc toutes ces réflexions là
ont aujourd'hui leur base qui est dans
le texte de la loi Agen mais évidemment
et je le dis vraiment en toute
simplicité à nous maintenant et vous
l'avez dit tout n'est pas parfait moi je
suis en plein dans la réévaluation moi
je continue d'avoir comment voilà
comment évolue ce texte de loi qu'est-ce
qui fonctionne qu'est-ce qui ne
fonctionne pas qu'est-ce qui mérite
d'être
revu à améliorer etc et c'est tout le
sens en fait de la loi hajjec mais moi
ce que je dis c'est qu'elle n'est pas
parfaite elle n'est certainement pas
achever au sens même de résoudre tous
les problèmes mais c'est une très belle
amorce et je crois qu'il faut le prendre
comme tel et donc là maintenant personne
ne peut dire je ne savais pas et je ne
peux pas faire si je ne peux pas faire
et bien on va essayer de trouver
ensemble la solution et je crois que
c'est un petit peu le sens de du
travaille aussi des élus des élus dans
les territoires juste pour ceux qui nous
écoutent l'oiseau c'est la loi relative
à la lutte contre le gaspillage et à
l'économie circulaire d'abord Guillaume
parce que juste un petit mot je peux pas
être plus d'accord avec l'idée que le
déchet est une ressource ça c'est
certain mais j'ajoute que pour nous le
fait qu'il y ait qui est ce statut de
déchet est effectivement très protecteur
parce que c'est ce qui permet de
rassurer parce que ça veut dire qu'il y
a une norme ça veut dire qu'il y a des
contrôles ça veut dire qu'il y a des
règlements et ce qui nous permet nous de
dire c'est un déchet c'est dans une
catégorie on va on va être transparent
sur la façon dont on utilise donc le
fait que les pouvoirs publics se
saisissent de ça catégorise et crée des
règles nous on aime beaucoup ça parce
qu'on est capable de les suivre est-ce
que puisque Martinique a dit que c'était
madame déchet puisque formulé cette loi
de lutte contre le gaspillage est-ce que
vous êtes le monsieur déchet de
Gargenville le monsieur déchet de
Villepreux d'abord il y a le perron
alors si si vous me permettez de
rebondir sur les sur les propos de la
sénatrice la problématique de de
récolter l'ensemble des déchets qu'on
produit sur un territoire donné
et de leur donner une seconde vie et de
leur donner une seconde vie près des
territoires là où ils sont produits
évidemment aujourd'hui on voit bien sur
la problématique du papier et du carton
puisque l'ensemble de nos administrés
sont contraints avec plus ou moins de
rigueur de trier et donc on se retrouve
avec des volumes de papier de carton à
traiter qui sont aujourd'hui quasiment
sans valeur pourquoi parce que le
déplacement des tonnes de papier et de
carton pour leur trouver un site de
reconditionnement et trop éloigné et et
le coût du transport est supérieur à la
valeur propre du papier donc aujourd'hui
on avait sur nos territoires on l'avait
à Nanterre on l'avait à Vernon on
l'avait à Rouen et peut-être cette unité
de retraitement se remettre à un jour en
marche puisqu'elle a pas encore été
démantelée mais en tout cas on avait des
unités de reconditionnement de nos
matériaux produits sur le territoire et
ça ça apportait de la valeur ajoutée ce
qui est plus le cas aujourd'hui parce
que transférer du papier récolté en
Île-de-France pour aller le traiter en
Allemagne en Afrique ou en Pays-Bas n'a
plus aucun sens en terme écologique
j'entends et encore moins économique sur
la sur le sur le fait que je suis
monsieur écologiste
évidemment je suis plutôt volontariste
dans ce domaine
je suis en pleine négociation avec la
communauté urbaine pour agrandir ma
déchetterie pour pour offrir un lieu
d'accueil propice à
déterminer à déterminer l'apport de nos
administrés de l'ensemble de leurs
déchets et pas aller sur du lieu plutôt
sur du dépôt sauvage l'idée c'est
vraiment d'élargir les heures
d'ouverture de simplifier le
déchargement des déchets de pas avoir
des bennes avec des des garde-corps 1 m
du sol etc et donc il y a toutes ces
problématiques aussi qui rentrent en
ligne de compte c'est la fluidité du
dépôt dans les déchetteries parce que
finalement il est bien plus simple pour
la plupart de de nos administrer d'aller
ouvrir le coffre en forêt et de tout
jeter par terre en 3 minutes que de
faire la queue une demi-heure devant une
déchetterie de se trouver devant un
garde-corps et de pas avoir la force de
jeter son tas de carton ou son sac
d'herbe particulière de corps et on est
tous confrontés à ce genre de
problématique pourquoi parce que il y a
un manque de fluidité et les structures
sont pas suffisamment accueillantes pour
déterminer l'apport du déchet
directement déchetterie
Jean-Baptiste harmonique
oui je crois pas que madame la sénatrice
nous-mêmes soyons Madame ou Monsieur
déjà en tout cas je sais que Madame
sénatrice et Madame économie circulaire
parce que elle a vraiment beaucoup
pleuré sur ce texte et je crois que à
l'époque j'avais d'autres fonctions mais
j'avais suivi effectivement son travail
parlementaire et ça a été fait en bonne
intelligence entre les deux chambres et
avec l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires parce que je crois que
c'est une thématique qui dépasse des
clivages politiques bien sûr moi le la
revalorisation des déchets alors il y a
deux choses je rebondis sur les dépôts
les dépôts sauvages nous on n'a pas de
décharge à ciel ouvert et donc on a pas
ce on n'est pas vraiment concerné par
les décharges illégales illicites sur
des territoires agricoles ou autre c'est
plutôt en cœur urbain que j'ai ça et je
suis très fâché avec ce qu'on appelle
les points d'apport volontaire de
déchets parce que les points d'Apple des
points d'apport volontaire de déchets
appelle le déchet en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je le vois ça nécessite
aussi d'avoir un travail avec les
promoteurs et les constructeurs pour
qu'on ait aussi des locaux notamment
encombrants qui soient prévu dans les
programmes à l'heure où tout le monde
essaye d'optimiser justement le mètre
carré mais c'est important parce que je
le signale sinon ça veut dire que on a
des particuliers qui saisissent
justement de ces petits points d'apport
de déchets volontaire pour en pensant
que ce sont des dépotoirs ils peuvent
tout mettre donc moi j'ai l'impression
d'être monsieur déchet quand le lundi
matin je suis obligé d'envoyer un
message technique faire le tour de la
ville et malheureusement c'est autant de
temps consacré à cette mission qui ne
peuvent pas consacrer à d'autres choses
et notamment à l'entretien de la commune
ça a été dit tout à l'heure nous on a
avancé sur une innovation une
expérimentation au niveau de notre
cuisine centrale sur le recyclage et le
traitement in situ des biodéchets avec
un électrocomposteur dont on va très
très prochainement tiré le bilan de
cette expérimentation
la loi de toute façon va nous demander
d'avancer sur ces questions là donc je
dirais qu'on on cherche à innover on
cherche des solutions très concrètes
dans une légique aussi de circuits
courts donc nous on est plutôt focalisé
sur sur cet aspect là des choses sur la
commune de Villepreux voilà il y a des
choses intéressantes je trouve qui sont
portées aussi par les entreprises par le
secteur arriver et je crois que
finalement un des fils rouges on a pu le
voir depuis le début de de notre table
ronde et notamment tout à l'heure aussi
avec total c'est que je crois que tous
ces enjeux là appellent la mobilisation
de l'ensemble des acteurs les
collectivités évidemment le privé avec
les entreprises il faut pas les opposer
je crois que les solutions doivent être
partagées et que les actions doivent
être partagées sur les territoires pour
leur application concrète et on a
beaucoup parlé aussi de nos concitoyens
il y a de la pédagogie encore à faire
alors sur les déchets moi je vous avoue
que la pédagogie on la fait mais je
passe aussi à un volet maintenant de
sanctions quand c'est nécessaire ce que
je pense que la lutte contre les dépôts
sauvages notamment avec les nouveaux
outils dont nous a dotés la loi il faut
pouvoir les utiliser et les porter à bon
escient mais voilà je crois que sur
toute cette thématique là du
développement durable de l'environnement
au sens le plus large du terme
j'ai la faiblesse de penser que la prise
de conscience est là
maintenant faut la concrétiser il faut
transformer l'essai et là il faut qu'on
arrive à faire je pense comprendre à
tout le monde que on est dans on est
dans l'urgence je commence à à être un
petit peu fâché avec le terme de
transition écologique et transition
énergétique même si évidemment la
transition comprend ce que ça veut dire
c'est l'accompagnement des acteurs qui
vont être concernés évidemment par ces
changements parce que tout changement
mérite d'être accompagné et évidemment
soutenu mais je crois qu'on a plus le
temps d'être dans la transition là faut
qu'on soit vraiment dans l'action et là
encore une fois je crois qu'il faut que
on arrive à continuer à ça a été dit
très justement tout à l'heure à avoir
des solutions très locales et périodes
territorialisées sur des bassins de vie
sur des bassins de population et je
crois que de mettre autour de la table
les entreprises les collectivités et nos
concitoyens c'est indispensable si on
veut réussir ce grand défi et bien on va
conclure sur ces propos justement de
l'action collective de ne pas opposer
aussi on retiendra ne pas opposer
peut-être un mot de conclusion je
voudrais juste rappeler très simplement
qu'aujourd'hui on s'interroge très
sérieusement sur ce que ça coûte de ne
pas s'occuper de l'environnement dans
nos territoires c'est un véritable coûte
j'ai changé il n'y a pas très longtemps
avec Madame l'ambassadrice madame le met
sur cette thématique là et aujourd'hui
le législateur envisage de se saisir
aussi de ce que ça coûte de ne pas faire
de l'environnement dans nos territoires
va falloir vraiment s'occuper et
regarder ce qui se passe au Parlement
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de lois qui
sont discutés dans ces prochains mois
merci Yann perron maire de Gargenville
Jean-Baptiste amonique maire de
villepeux vice-président charge des
transports à 50 ans en Yvelines Martin
de Sidrac sénatrice des Yvelines et
Guillaume Pasquier directeur du
développement du groupe ect merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
[Musique]